what's up everybody
this is zacky from geek culture and
today we will be unboxing the star wars
the vintage collection the mandalorian
atsd raider toy vehicle
this ats-t raider toy is inspired by the
vehicles in the mandalorian the upcoming
series premiering on disney plus on
november 12th this year
not much is known about the series so
far though we know it will take place
five years after the events of return of
the jedi and follows the journey of a
mandalorian bounty hunter
first and foremost is the vintage
inspired packaging itself
it features the original kenner toys
branding which has produced several
highly recognizable toys and merchandise
some of you may remember the action
figures from the original series of star
wars and jurassic park
out of the box we get a disassembled
atst and a cletunian atsd pilot
now not much is known about how tatooine
and the mandalorian fits into the story
but what we can say is that this variant
of the all-terrain scout transport
vehicle is used by a platoonian raider
after the fall of the galactic empire
the claretonian atsd raider features an
opening cockpit articulated legs
adjustable laser cannons
side mounted weapon pods
[Music]
and movable command viewpoint blast
shield this atsd also sports a new paint
job that we will probably see in the
show
customized with tatooinian decals and
paint work fabric material and a net it
just goes to show how much detail it
went to make this figure and the user
speculating for what is to come
and it's also compatible with 3.75 inch
scale star wars action figures and what
a better way than to show it off with
the figurines from the commemorative
edition skywalker saga
these are the first wave of 3.75 inch
gold figure two packs in this new series
right out of the bat
there's a metallic four packaging on the
print
if you flip to the back each of these
boxes have their respective prints from
the prequel trilogy
episode 1 phantom menace in 1999 which
features darth maul and yoda
episode 2 attack of the clothes in 2002
with mace windu and jungle fat and
episode 3 revenge of the sith in 2005
with obi-wan and anakin skywalker
with that we hope you enjoyed this
unboxing of the platoonian atst raider
toy and the figures from the skywalker
saga
if you like to know more about these
goodies be sure to check out the link in
the description below don't forget to
slam that subscribe button and tell us
about what you would like us to unbox
next
see you on the next one until then stay
geeky